this is called dick in a tree hey you
guys will see an impression of the
window what's going on everybody I'm
Kevin Hart
I am Dwayne Johnson so yeah being that
we're in the Christmas spirit I want to
wrap each other and treat each other
like Christmas trees you see who does a
better job at the end we're gonna decide
like who who is the best Christmas
rapper I was gonna wrap everything don't
have to be torn apart
I'm get excited watch my hair guys do we
have a puzzle so tell everybody at home
Wi-Fi below what did you enjoy most
about Jumanji other than me we have an
amazing cast we have Jack Black Karen
Gillan Nick Jonas myself didn't need the
wings now that I think about it always
you know we all felt like it should have
been called without the wing for my
creative process with this I figure
Kevin Hart first of all you got to start
with the paper metaphors a football
represents how Kevin became famous
thanks Chuck its eyes Denzel
I've heard to everyone that lad Bible
from okay if it isn't lad hey you guys
want to see an impression of uh of the
way in the rock Johnson but now
[Applause]
I'm gonna tell you what i'ma do to you
it's tonight tonight it's my turn to uh
to wrap the Wayne of rock Johnson just
focus Clark please it's gonna be a good
tree one of the important balls this is
a great tree yeah give me two more
seconds guys and hold on hold on this is
called dick in a tree
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Man I mean god I wish I could
say I was shocked I thought I did a
better tree [ __ ] gonna dick in it dick
in a tree okay guys bye it's always that
Bible always a pleasure we love you guys
we always have a blast every time we
come and we work with you guys and thank
you for loving me more